this guy's stolen man make sure y'all
get my [ __ ] make sure y'all play this
yeah come out
all right follow
look
[Music]
okay my mind been on some other [ __ ]
connecting all the dots i'm doing 45 a
play [ __ ] i forgot to call my brother
back they just make it sound dope i
really live it it was on a different
scale as kids but we knew the business
[ __ ] take a l we get back on track
cause we invested in this [ __ ] we don't
just get that facts so why else we
supposed to wear our hats it's starting
to blow me higher chains don't match we
spin the block and then do one more
let's get it never mind that i lost it i
couldn't find it i got my hands on the
gold i said [ __ ] it i bought some
diamonds i'm lit i'm on the rise while i
sit i'm getting high while i [ __ ] i take
a shower we out but we saying hi to my
[ __ ] look i like the solitude the solid
[ __ ] power moves even when they white
girls get changes and they molecules you
see i'm getting ridiculed for admitting
i'm a sinner but it's cool no a [ __ ]
been a fool with it any city chicken
spot i'm kicking cool bender shawty only
with us to show off our new titties
titties babies spend 30 on titties
titties now i'm back folk my wife cold
and [ __ ] at her back though but why
would i react for if [ __ ] really slide
i'ma give them what they ask for
ironically at this time the law gonna
let my mass go so i'ma be all through
his crib like [ __ ] it waving around my
favorite handgun i might bust it my
attitude got a red button don't touch it
stupid [ __ ] steady thinking i'm
bluffing [ __ ] it [ __ ] them look
i ain't going up from it i want the
money just make it a honey bun i don't
care if it's all that hunters i go out
for the funds they go out for some fun
until the sun come up hoping her pants
come down but my money up crazy and i'm
handsome now and the right questions to
bring the right answers out so i doing
no dancing unless this diamonds on my
wrist with the stars on the stage and
three thousand on the mix they couldn't
bring me back to houston i was on some
other [ __ ] i just go and get the money
till the problems don't exist james
think i'm crazy when i'm whiling in the
whips i had the rockets on my jersey
with a rocket on my hip and i lock it on
my neck because my baby mama popping and
she watching like a hawking helicopter
with that [ __ ] chopper on her
lap the nda4 they can't even document
this [ __ ] gotta acknowledge it's legit i
was sitting at the crib thinking how i
make a list i'm supposed to be the
hooper and little baby never miss how i
get it to these people on a platter with
a fish on top of salad on the island if
they traveling and [ __ ] for the fuzz and
gds and the travelers and [ __ ] like
chicago in this [ __ ] because it's the
motto in this [ __ ] oh paul smoked paul
we brought the bottle in this [ __ ] we
could scarred off a handle still can
handle any whip whether the trans is
automatic we gonna ride it [ __ ] pause
it that was crazy y'all catch it don't
get cancelled [ __ ] rap right
dumb that uh
yo
i said [ __ ] it i got it my [ __ ] hyping
my [ __ ] rap but they hide it they
really be trying to time it we really
don't play with [ __ ] that tried and
reached for diamonds i just converted
the glock out of drum and this [ __ ] a
tommy gun i needed money for i ever knew
what designer was the brick house was
anything but the commodores the homie
showed me the benefits of the
counterfeit so i counted mine one more
time then the counter did yeah get your
fix we with it everybody quarterback
until they see a blitz i get it i'll
take a quarterback to break the rest
down let's get it i fronted it all i
want the whole thing plus interest
concrete island we ain't really used to
the water we make it rain with the cash
to get a crib for your mama if you could
swim to get in we got a pool full of
dollars can't put it into the scene with
the blue on the collars we really from
it my [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
this car ain't stolen this guy is stolen
man
i want the money to make it up and i
want everyone to know too
on spotify your [ __ ] is just iman yeah
it's just iman peter there's an iman
profile up there
somebody i think somebody else got
control of that bro yeah you i'm about
to say it's confusing so if you go on
spotify just in mind that's it no mind
period just put a period at the end so
it's like this i i think about it like
this right
take the last name off my name that was
for basketball that was on new jersey if
i'm in a jersey shampoo
off the court you wouldn't call me mine
yeah just call me mom bro i ain't got to
be stumped i'm not my name iman you came
up here and caught the body man oh you
[ __ ] with it you caught a body oh spit
that [ __ ] one time we got guys who like
do this like full time for the last 10
or 15 years and they'll you they'll [ __ ]
up like 30 times before they actually
nail their [ __ ] no oh yeah
i didn't know that oh yeah good job yeah
you killed it i swear to god bro there's
times where we've been in here for like
45 minutes waiting for someone to nail a
minute long freestyle and we'll be like
come on dude no way yeah we won't say
name
no yeah you killed it oh oh
some of the best rappers in the world
will have their phone
and they'll have like you know how you
got your sweaters here
so they'll have their phone with the
lyrics over here off camera
and they'll be like oh try yeah it
happens oh
damn i should have did that so this guy
just caught a i mean you just i should
have did that
if i didn't did that i'd have got over
y'all last night you already you did
though at this point though this guy is
stolen you know what i'm saying y'all go
rock with the album you know what i'm
saying listen to that i want to come out
outside it's already out yeah like i
just the most honest i ever came so it's
like this is how i'm coming so i hope
y'all rocking with it and um you know at
this point it's center gang like we
at this point on full rap mode so you
know
at any time y'all could send y'all this
in y'all could sing y'all this song
again and get you i wouldn't mind a nice
a nice like uh like like loves a rap
beat maybe you and dame lillard go back
and forth no that's not rap
going to turn it into a 101
let's take it to the court let's take it
to the court